following deals to relocate refugees
across most of the EU MEP s have passed
a 400 million euro package to tackle
immediate needs including support for
countries dealing with first arrivals
they can take care of refugees coming
and they come to find out proper place
and they can give them effective and
rapid eight so it's it's really urgent
budgets committee members agreed to help
frontline countries like Turkey Lebanon
and Jordan handling millions of Syrian
and Iraqi refugees as well as UN support
agencies they're also beefed up the EU
police and border agencies from Texas
and Europol and the European Asylum
support office a clear signal that we
are giving is the EU budget is part of
tackling this a huge challenge but of
course it is not the EU budget alone
we're not sold with EU member states
also have to besides declarations commit
commit significant amounts of money the
allocations drawn the 2015 budget and go
to a full vote on Wednesday negotiations
are underway for a subsequent 700
million euro program from the draft 2016
budget